nous avons quelques questions à vous
poser
d'accord où étiez-vous la nuit ou
lillibridge a disparu
même si je te présente lille i lille
lucie fly alors tu es au japon depuis
combien de temps ça fait environ trois
semaines maintenant
c'est bizarre comment tout le monde nous
fixe au japon c'est comme si on était
ses lèvres
[Musique]
oui certains deviennent accros à ça vous
n'êtes pas comme tout le monde vous non
plus
alors ne faisons pas semblant
tu prends tout en photo
bien sûr
d'un petit ami oui il est trop mignon
mignon
bon d'accord il est superbe
il al'air obsédé parfois qu'est ce qui
te fait dire ça je connais les hommes
c'est un sacré numéro
on dirait que tu es le seul qui existe
et puis elle passe à quelqu'un d'autre
et c'est comme si tu avais jamais existé
qu'est ce que tu vois pour les retenir
s'il te plaît
on a quelque chose que personne d'autre
ne pourrait partager
tu ne suis pas bien sûr que si
qu'est ce que tu racontes je sais ce que
je ressens
tu dois me faire confiance
c'est la seule personne qui ait jamais
de qui
l'impression qui va se passer quelque
chose d'extrêmement craint